[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for tuning in again to another
episode of the dean show so many
misconceptions about the fastest growing
way of life in the world today
yet most misunderstood so we're gonna be
clearing up some of these misconceptions
islam calling you to blow up yourself
blow up innocent people oh it was
created by a man in the desert and you
know what they the antichrist and all
this other phony baloney nonsense that
we're going to be addressing here on the
dean show
with
imam john yahya we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
and we've done a show with you in the
past people can go to thedeanshow.com to
hear your story you're born again
christian before it had a catholic and
then you were in the agnostic uh phase
you're like you know what hey you know
i'm not digging this but you know i'm
going towards what you know what's next
agnosticism i kind of
believe i don't what's out there you
read the quran verbatim word of god
you've even memorized it's a miracle
that people have memorized it and you
are not even a native speaking arab
but you've memorized this entire book is
this true
this is a blessing that i was given a
very also a responsibility to keep that
up but yes i was given that
blessing now was your dad and mom half
arab or something no no pure uh bread
american yeah born and raised yeah now
that's a phenomena you're an american
who didn't grow up speaking arabic but
you've memorized that's one of the
miracles of this book the quran it's a
living miracle that people if they're
searching the truth they can come
analyze it and they'll see that this
can't come from muhammad or any group of
men or aliens space martians the devil
or some say that's you know this con
they'll realize like you did this is
from the creator of all that exists is
that what you realize oh naturally
now let's start off with it because time
is short let's start off because we're
talking about misconceptions many people
have misconceptions about this way of
life that's from the creator it's not
made by a group of men or the last and
final messenger of muhammad but for
those that believe that muhammad
concocted this yes what do you got to
say
you see
the crusades
were historically written and they're
known
to be
after muslims gain prominence and
dominance in the political arenas
miraculously toppling the persian and
the byzantium empires
basically taking a third of the
civilized world into its uh realm
um
the
catholic or the christian roman
group decided we need to start waging
wars and to take back and kill all of
these muslims and by the way during that
time muslims and jews were living
together and as a matter of fact when
these crusaders came these christians
by the command of the pope
according to his understanding that he's
receiving a decree from god to go spread
bloodshed in the name of god as they
believe it was jesus and the father and
the son
so when this
happened
there was this of course enmity and so
muslims and jews fought together
defending their lands and everything and
even some of the local christian priests
and people
preferred the muslim just rule
over
the
rule of the um the roman empire so after
that after that happened
the crusades did not start there
crusades did not stop there
there formed a group called orientalists
they started to look into history and
write it from their perspective in order
to discredit islam in the intellectual
arena to try to develop a theory
as to how we can somehow prove or at
least make our own evidence
to make islam seem like obviously some
false pagan to an extent that they claim
that we worship the moon they said that
we worshiped pagan gods and we said we
worship muhammad they tried to cast on
to us the name muhammadians
and they wrote this in their books in
england and france and germany and
poland and later portugal and spain
elsewhere
so
part of that
claim or that attack was to say that
muhammad peace be upon him
was
they admit they read history he was a
good young man with good morals and
manners was not evil was not corrupt was
not even known to lie his people called
him assad
the truthful trustworthy man that they
would go to when they would get in
corrupt disputes
but at some point they said
he got this
uh they have two stories and it's
interesting and you should all read gary
miller's um analysis of this was a great
a reverb muslim gary miller they can go
go online google and just put gary and
quran gary miller about prophet muhammed
and so one
group says
muhammad traveled in the narrations of
history we have two trips
once when he was a young boy he went
with abu talib his uncle
to the area of syria where there is
a
prevalence of christian people
one of the narrations which muslims
often try to use as proof but many of
the muslim scholars of hadith
took issue with the hadith says that
there was indeed some sort of a
priest or monk that was amazed by
muhammad and was telling him about
prophethood and so they're they're
concocting the story that muhammad spent
time learning about the previous
messages of christianity and judaism and
so forth because obviously in mecca
those are very rare to find anybody that
believes it much less knows much about
it
and so
after that one trip when he was 12 then
whenever he was 20 something he went
with khadijah who at that point was just
the owner of the caravan he worked for
um and then he went there again so these
are two events that narrate that the
prophet muhammad went with the caravan
now on either of these events
nobody narrates that he spent time
studying
with any priest
the one story from the beginning when he
was 12 right says that a priest told him
you have the signs of prophethood or you
could be a prophet and this and that but
there is no discussion that he had long
discussions which you would need to have
to form a full book that knows
everything about the previous book right
especially since you're an illiterate
arab man who doesn't know
aramaic or assyrian or greek language
which is what they're speaking over
there a mixture of these three right so
so that story is is totally
baseless for muslims we believe it to be
blasphemy if someone were to say
muhammad is the founder of islam
that's blasphemy right we believe that
god
created the creation and made a system
that creation will submit to his will
and all of creation will do that except
for he will call out to creation
and offer it the great trust
it's in the end of swaziland
so he says who will take the trust or
the responsibility of having
their own consciousness to know right
and wrong and then be responsible for
doing the right thing
all of creation said no
everything animals suns planets
everything
communicated to god that we're just
going to follow your system that you
have designed for us
atoms protons neutrons electrons
following their course without any
disturbance we're just going to do what
you said and be peaceful in that state
human being by nature said
i believe that i can take this and this
is what
our brothers and sisters from humanity
you hear them saying
that they create that god created man in
his image
obviously we are not god is not a human
or anything that you can imagine um but
his image is more of a metaphor that he
has this creative ability to control the
environment and do what he wants with it
and he can make decisions and conscious
decisions about it and so having that
control is something that human beings
amongst all of the creation have been
blessed with so when he sent these
prophets this prophet's message all of
them was to submit to the will of god as
a matter of fact in the book of matthew
in the new testament jesus said to a guy
who came saying master master lord lord
whichever translation you want to take
he said
whoever says to me lord lord will not
enter the kingdom of heaven but he who
does the will of the father in heaven
metaphorical father that god is the
creator of everything and so
that is he's clearly teaching submit to
the will of god it's not just by saying
i'm your lord or i'm your master as the
prophet you have to do the will of god
so
um islam is not something
that any human can make up it is
something that god
reveals so going back to gary miller
he's it's interesting because some of
the other orientalists
they looked at the arguments that their
predecessors made that he got full of
himself used some knowledge he got from
syria and then developed this religion
which is based in the
judeo-christian
tradition but then they said but if you
read more about his life and his example
he obviously believed
that he was the prophet i mean when he's
staying up all night praying and his
feet are cracking from soreness and
aisha his wife be uh
god be pleased with her she says why are
you praying all night god you're the
prophet your sins have been forgiven if
you ever made a mistake in your life you
know you're you're clear you've been
given prophethood and so then he said
shouldn't i be a grateful servant when
he attained power and political
dominance he could have built a palace
and had very beautiful women but never
did he do any of this his life testified
to the fact that he truly believed so
then they developed a new theory prophet
muhammad was insane
he was crazy he was talked to by jinns
or
demons or devils and so they gave him
these ideas and so he was fooled about
this so now the other argument that
you're saying is basically you're saying
that this man who is possessed by demons
or crazy or insane or epileptic or
whatever story you're going to make
he basically
changed the fabric of history took a
society that was in anarchy and chaos
and drunkenness and lewdness burying
baby girls and then transformed them
into a law-abiding people of discipline
of kindness of mercy compassion of
justice defending the oppressed muslim
or non-muslim and so forth
this was what happened as a result of
his
actions so you're saying some crazy men
um impacted billions of people in world
history and and caused them to be a
rightly uh upright people with good
manners and good character that also
doesn't add up so they keep chasing
around that well obviously they say he
must have been making this up and he was
just good at fooling people that he
really believed that so it just doesn't
end in their round it's like a my mouse
and the dog chasing his tail yeah it
doesn't make sense we're going to
continue with more we got to go to break
we'll be right back with more here in
the dean's show everybody in deep down
they believe that there is a god yeah
and as much as they deny it
[Music]
if god exists and he does
if god sends prophets and he does if god
reveals books and he does should he not
tell me how to live my life doesn't that
make sense happiness and truth
in life
back here on the dean show with imam jan
yahya that's coming from john the
baptist and then it's a messenger of god
just like jesus was a messenger abraham
noah and the last and final measure
prophet muhammad peace be upon them all
that came with the same message worship
the creator not his creation and that is
what you concluded from the quran
verbatim word of god
that we believe just like jesus believed
and his followers true followers and
moses and their true followers and
abraham and those true fathers we're
continuing the legacy of worshiping only
god just the creator not his creation
some people are upset about this because
you know what we're saying look in a
kind and benign way that look jesus is
not god yeah never claim to be god we're
not putting jesus down we love jesus you
can't be a muslim unless you're jesus
right we believe jesus was muslim
because he submitted to the god to god
and that's what a muslim is so they make
up all these different
false
accusations about islam we're clearing
those up here on the dean show i really
want to get to more of them because
there's so many but we can't touch upon
all of them so you talked about one
and then we'll direct people where they
can go for further assistance on this to
clear up these false fallacies
that anyone just a couple more points
and we've got to move on to the next did
anyone yell out because there's a lot of
information
on prophecies accuracy scientific facts
not fiction it's all in this book so
that anyone if he's copying from someone
yell out and say hey he got it from me
you know how somebody want credit is
there anyone who yelled up and said no i
said that i gave it to him and that's
that's a very interesting point that
when the people of mecca disbelieved in
him
nobody said
they were waiting for any way to try to
prove him wrong they were watching him
like a heart listening to all the verses
trying to find something wrong with it
trying to but nobody ever came out it's
never been narrated not by polytheists
not by muslims not by anybody in history
that at some point somebody came out and
said yeah but we saw him learning from
the christians the only claim was very
interesting is that they claimed that he
learned from a persian man who is
neither christian nor jew
the one argument they said that he's
learning things about the quran is that
he learned them from a persian man
who was neither christian nor jew now
looking at that and anybody who read the
quran and seeing at the
depths and accuracy for example just
read the story of joseph youssef
it is a long detailed analysis of the
life of the prophet joseph the son of
jacob
now talking to some persian guy who's
not christian or jew when you don't even
know persian language right and he knows
arabic as a second language i don't
think you can get that anywhere near
that accuracy and depth in it and that
was the message of the story of yusuf is
to respond to the claims that he has
just this basis basic knowledge of stuff
and so when in depth to show he has
whatever god allows him to have and it's
very extensive whatever weren't some of
the chief now who used to be pagans even
some jewish rabbis there's one story if
you can go ahead and
elaborate on this where the jewish rabbi
he had seen prophet muhammad and he was
like this fits the signs of the
messengers coming but there was two that
were missing so he went to get his debt
back and he like pulled his cloak and he
was like give me my money really
obnoxious it was all a setup to see how
he's going to react but later he ended
up accepting islam can you go ahead and
talk about this for a minute you see
that's one point that
when i discuss with our
brothers and sisters from the jewish
tradition
i asked them why were these three huge
rabbinical tribes in yet
why yathrib is
about a four hour drive northeast of
mecca and it's in the hot spot of the
desert there's nothing there it's just
desert there is not vegetation there is
not
to catch up with the
financial opportunities you have to go
between mecca and syria which medina is
over here outside of that this is like
no man's land right right and it's very
hot but they claimed themselves
that we are waiting for our great
prophet that we know is going to come
and it was mentioned in deuteronomy
chapter 18 verses 16 through 18 that i
will send a prophet and he will be like
moses and he will speak in my name god
is saying and of course every chapter of
the quran begins in the name of god
and it says that um that you must
believe in that prophet he's going to
come and i will he will say what i
command him the quran always says
in the singular say he's commanded by
god to say
very clear prophecies more clear than
any messianic prophecy applying to what
we know to be jesus the messiah in this
is so then the new testament has the
same thing when john the baptist was
being spoken to
um by the sadducees and the pharisees
the rabbis
that um john the baptist are you the
messiah he says no i'm not the messiah
and i said are you elijah because i have
all these stories about elijah coming in
and out of the
the the history he says no i'm not
elijah and they said are you the prophet
and he says no i'm not the prophet this
is an interesting point because
in the time of the new testament
the jews obviously were awaiting three
prophecies that's why they're asking him
these three things are you the messiah
no okay we're waiting for an elijah that
we understand or are you the prophet now
in many biblical commentaries on the
prophet they put a cross reference to
deuteronomy chapter 18 16-17
so
it's saying that the prophet is
something old testament news testament
confirmed now in arabia in the time of
muhammad there were three big jewish
rabbinically laced tribes who were
awaiting a prophet and they used to say
yesterday
that they used to say when our prophet
comes we're going to take full control
over these lands he's going to be a
dominant force the jews were saying to
the polytheist pagans of yatrib
so when these people of yatrib heard
about muhammad they came and talked to
him and asked him questions getting to
your point whenever he came
the prophet muhammad peace be upon him
when the people embraced a lot of the
tribal heads and so forth embraced
embraced his message and accepted him as
the final messenger of god that these
jews have been telling them about and so
it was much easier for them than the
people in mecca because they have these
people telling them there's going to be
a great prophet he's going to do this
that and say this that and other and
he's going to confirm confirm our truths
and become this dominant force
so they embraced him well amongst them
was a man
his name actually was hussein
and so
is one of the uh
prominent rabbis amongst prominent now
yeah he was high up there with now
that's according to their statement as
you will see and so he basically knew of
the prophethood and he knew that when
the news came about muhammad the the
natural see what happened to the jewish
nation they became a race racial or you
could even say racist movement because
they divided the world between jews and
gentiles everybody who's not jew is a
gentile they're not the chosen people of
god they're not specially blessed like
us we are the chosen people of god right
and so they negated that there were any
ever any prophets for anybody else and
so forth and so they were saying that
only prophethood can come to us all the
rest of the people were left in astray
where the quran says that's obviously
false they were given a special blessing
and a test and they allowed their selves
to become engulfed with that
reality that ego
so then they they all said amongst
themselves yes okay maybe he fulfills a
lot of what we're saying but he's not
from our and they they even said that
because he's not from
the isaac he's from the ishmael lineage
and ishmael was just from a slave woman
so this idea they developed about why he
can't be accepted so hussein islam said
no i'm going to go talk to him and find
out so when the prophet muhammad came he
came and he asked him about the three
signs and then he
actualized and he gave his testimony of
faith so then
the prophet muhammad was elated peace be
upon him this great rabbi and so with
now all of the beautiful people of god
are going to embrace the people of the
book he said no no no no i can tell you
right now i'm going to be your only
supporter
these people will not and he says why
you know you have the torah you've been
reading the scripture he's like but we
don't read the torah just for sincerity
because we just want to be the people of
god we read it through a lens of a
certain dynasty or tradition of the
chosen people and so the fact that
you're coming from outside of our tribes
we are assuming
even though that's not clear-cut written
in this prophecy but we're assuming that
that prophet should come from our blood
and not from anywhere else and so
they're not going to accept you so then
he told them that i'm going to uh show
you
uh the prophet muhammad said okay i'm
going to announce my prophethood to them
and he said just tell them
see what they say about me and then
and then you say i became muslim and
then see what they say about me and
you'll see where they're coming from so
the prophet muhammad peace be upon him
he goes to them and he says you know i'm
the problem they said this is nonsense
you're a liar you're a fool you're the
you know great great grandson of a slave
woman and all of this
and so then
he said
hussain even
has embraced my message they said that's
impossible you're a liar times 10. he's
the scholar the son of a scholar the son
of a sage of our great saints and so
forth and then he said i'm telling you
he's he's a muslim and then abdullah ibn
hussein he changed his name
he came around and he says
yes i bear witness that god is one and
this is the final messenger of god that
we've been with the top rabbi yeah the
jews at the top but one of the top yeah
and so then they all said oh this is
nonsense and so forth he's the liar the
son of the liar the son now they flipped
on him too so then the prophet muhammad
said how can you say that and then they
quickly look at their politics they're
good at politics historically very
well-based politics they said well when
you said and we don't know that he that
he said that to you he's one of ours
even though he's so bad and we know that
about him so we said what we said the
first time to protect unless we knew now
that we know that he is showing his
corruption by claiming this to you and
we have to tell you what we really know
about him because we thought he was
lying the first time and so
this attitude was there and abdullah
hussain he said you know what
abdullah in
he said you know what i'm not worshiping
a tradition of people and that's where
names come from judaism the tribe of
judah this special people on earth
christianity christ a man named christ
great as he may be blessed with
revelation and prophethood he's a human
buddhism that buddhism a man named
buddha hinduism the land of hind
baha'i
islam is the only name
that directs you directly submission to
the will of god and not any human and so
he recognized that he knows that and he
knows that we should not attach
ourselves to worldly material beliefs of
religion rather it should be a divine uh
reference that goes directly to god
we're going to take a break and we'll be
right back with some more here on the
dean show in paradise there's no death
yeah you know there's no sickness no
sickness
in a world of peace and tranquility no
wars no fighting no fighting
anything that you want yeah now you can
have it yeah in the in the paradise yeah
and god wants us to have that
but the price we have to pay is give up
the dunya
[Music]
back here on the dean show clearing up
the false fallacies the misconception so
the truth can be uncovered because this
is a treasure brings peace happiness and
fulfillment in life not only in this but
definitely in the next paradise and
islam is calling the goodness now to the
next misconception that people have i
got to get in a couple more please so
we're short on time quickly please
address this because now people are like
look there they go picking on the jews
picking on the christians and you know
what
this is what islam teaches hate all jews
and christians so let's start with this
next misconceptions excellent see
historically all people have bad
characters right now many muslims are
doing many ignorant things and foolish
things and i have no problem discussing
that and saying the muslims are not
producing in the world the muslims are
doing things backward the muslims are
oppressing women these are facts and
these are realities that muslims do
muslims doing it yeah not islam yeah
those are people who claim it judaism
which is originally
a message of god revealed to a people
that were blessed and chosen as the
quran says uh even says prader ford
that we prefer them over the nations of
the world with this blessing of
revelation
so jews and christians and all people of
the earth have good and have bad and we
recognize that about them and
the world has benefited from all jews
muslims christians and other people but
we cannot
in this political correct world
try to hide facts about any people
whether it be muslims jews or christians
so yes historically christians have been
uh disingenuous in writing muslim
history according to their crusade-based
intellectual war on islam and jews have
at times as we said before um
plotted against muslims and and attacked
the prophet muhammad and at other times
when the christians started crusades and
when the christians banished the jews
they were in the muslim till now
after all this talk about iran and all
of this and they're going to destroy
iran has a large population of jewish
people yemen they're saying yemen it's
now the base of al-qaeda has a large
population of jews you know where they
came from they've been there ever since
the islamic khalifa or caliphate
in which the islamic state was ruling
and they've been there they're very
devout they have the little curly things
with the hat traditional orthodox very
devout people they have their place they
have their temples they have their
tribes and they're respected for who
they are so there are good jews and bad
jews good muslims and bad muslims good
christians and bad christians so if we
mention something bad about a people it
doesn't mean we're against all of those
people we don't put them all in one
basket that is of course what people are
trying to do to muslims right now and
we're against that we recognize that
jews have done a lot for the advancement
of the world that christians have done a
lot of very beautiful acts of goodness
um you know building um
educational centers schools and and
hospitals for the the disenfranchised or
the less fortunate people muslims aren't
doing this so they're superior to us in
that in that we should compete with our
fellow neighbors in pr presenting islam
which is to submit to the god and bring
this mercy and bring this
intellectualism that jews and christians
have done we did historically we fell
down it's our time to show the beauty of
what we are and we should mention the
good about others as well as the
negative and need be because it's a part
of history and a reality that we have to
understand in context then we're going
to mention that we got to go to another
question but just to wrap this one up so
does the quran call muslims to kill all
jews and christians i challenge anybody
to bring me such a verse um in a
nutshell you will find a verse
in a chapter that was dealt with after
the muslims were oppressed and abused
for 13 years in mecca and then they went
escaping to yathrib and the muslims
there and the muslims there built a
strong
group
uh
leadership over that town
then after that basically
the uh
there were some breaking of treaties
that muhammad peace be upon him was the
initiator of writing a treaty when those
jews said we say you're a liar we're
saying you're this and that and other we
will never believe in you you know what
he said he had the authority to say
you're banished we will start a war with
you right now what did he do he said
let's write the treaty of medina a
historical
place in history in which a treaty was
written
by a theocratic ruler in which he
recognized the right of non-followers of
his tradition to follow and to be
citizens of the state and work together
to protect each other and and live
together in harmony and they did but
the polytheists convinced them to try to
destroy the muslims that they went
through that and they tried to so there
was a verse revealed after breaking
these treaties and which it did not say
to kill jews it said to
to fight the polytheists who have been
fighting you and attacking you and
oppressing you and give them four months
that if they cannot make peace and they
don't want to embrace islam then at that
point they can either leave the land
which they're free to do because they're
creating turmoil and bloodshed in this
area or they can stay and fight because
this war is a last means to attaining
peace i mean nobody in the united states
is going to deny that we need wars as a
last result whenever things are not
there's there's no peace so that's the
only reason it's there historically god
has revealed that in the torah it's it's
revealed historically that people have
to defend themselves and establish a
good moral society and if people are
trying to make turmoil or treason or
fighting or internal
plots against the nation then that's
that's seen as as as something that must
be stopped and of course we don't want
to go there but war is a nature of human
beings and god regulated it to where
when the prophet muhammad
saw a dead woman after a battle he was
very upset and he told them no woman no
child no monk no elderly person do not
burn down do not cut down trees
the battle is meant to stop these men
who represent
an oppressive force it is meant to stop
and subdue them
from their
evil ways and to attain peace for
society it's not meant to kill innocent
people so and the quran very clearly
says la taco
do not kill yourself so to kill yourself
and all these innocents is against a
clear verse of the quran and a clear
teaching of the prophet they're telling
us we're out of time we i just got to
get this in the last 30 seconds advice
because everyone's heart can change
everyone has until the moment of death
hell is a reality paradise is a reality
ultimate justice is on the day of
judgment islam is calling you to do good
to be good to develop yourself to have
the best character all in the footing
of pure monotheism so even for those out
there who are working day and night
fighting against islam it's become a big
business it's paid their paychecks right
a lot of money so even for those are out
there and they're fighting day and night
against islam maligning the last and
final message of prophet muhammad and
islam and the muslims and they're
working day and night to create fear and
havoc and to create this this concept of
like a boogeyman is coming to get you
sharia law and all this other phony
baloney nonsense what advice do you have
for them my advice to you is if you
happen to be a christian
read the gospel of jesus
he said do not judge the judge the
people who judge will be judged a harsh
judgment
do not be a liar do not be someone who
spreads corrupt ideas try to work
together if you don't want to embrace
islam or you don't want to believe in it
at least you can see the good in it just
like i see the good in the gospel of
jesus and i can work together with my
christian brothers and sisters in
humanity for good causes and helping the
poor and the needy and so forth let's
work together in a
morally deteriorating world to make this
place a better place let's not try to
create the clash of civilizations and
because what's crazy is that our
religion is against all that terrorism
but what they're doing and what some of
these policies are doing is really
developing the terrorism amongst muslims
they're doing things and spreading ideas
and making wars that are making ignorant
muslims that don't know about islam and
what it teaches and the nuances of
islamic law and how war engagement
should be done justly and according to a
certain uh just practice and so then
some guy says yeah we've got to get back
at those disbelievers and the invaders
and all of this so let's do this and
that so let's work against all that
let's be a peaceful people that work for
the good of society that see that look
if i'm not convinced with your dogma and
your dogmatic beliefs then you know fine
but let's not attack each other and you
know
you can say i don't believe islam but
yet islam and muslims do good here this
is what their beliefs are good i'm going
to work with them on that that's
perfectly fine but this is natural
that's it thank you very much for being
with us here on the dean's show look
forward to god we've got so much more
that we want to talk to you about next
time inshallah again
thank you very much my god almighty
thank you and again from the bottom of
our hearts from my heart definitely
thank you for tuning in and if you had
some missed notions misconceptions about
islam and muslims hopefully this episode
helped us off in your heart a little bit
and to see that you know what muslims
come from all walks of life i'm an
american muslim my guest is american
muslim and you can be a chinese muslim
an italian muslim because a muslim is
just like jesus moses abraham one who
consciously submits
not to
one's desires or to a nationality or to
a power hungry
whatever it may be
it's only to submit to the one who
created this whole universe and
everything and that's how you can get
peace happiness contentment paradise in
the next life and success in this life
and islam is not calling a human being
to create havoc in the land to spread
corruption and we got to hear a little
bit of the truth here on the dean show
here today with our guests so continue
to tune in to learn more and if you have
any other further questions give us a
call 1-800-662-islam
come to the muslims to learn sit with
the muslims and get to know the muslims
those who have submitted to the one god
and then you can make your judgment from
there and we'll see you next time pick
up the new dunya to dean also
at thedeanshow.com we look forward to
having you back again with us thank you
once again peace